welcome back so a great part about my
job is introducing our audience to young
good-looking talent
our next stand-up comedian is none of
that
please welcome joe devito
hello
thank you
thank you ah yes
yes
feel the relief factor kicking in you
can feel it
good to see you guys uh folks i'll be
honest i didn't get into show business
to become rich and famous and so far
mission accomplished
i think that's why the whole johnny depp
amber heard trial was so good for my
self-esteem
i needed to see good-looking wealthy
people who make worse choices than i do
because i've had some bad relationships
you know what i've never had someone
poop in my bed
never
so
maybe i've never known true love
but it uh it gave me a new definition
for the word deal breaker
and for the words amber alert
i've i've never been married and at age
53 i'm starting to think maybe it's me
[Applause]
but i do have hopes and dreams i'd like
to have kids one day
but just for the one day
very annoying
but i planned ahead i did i froze my
sperm years ago
yeah yeah and everyone said i was crazy
because i didn't go to like a place
[Applause]
but when you're you're single over a
certain age you have to be very direct
you have to be right on the money i tell
people if you're over 50 and you're
dating online first words to your
profile should be all right look
you're no bargain either
and you take it from there
i don't use the dating technology
anymore no more apps nothing someone
said to me they asked me if i do sexting
i said sexy do you have any idea
how big my font is
okay
you can read my text from your phone
okay
i can't see they come in one letter at a
time like a fax machine
not sex there's nothing sexy about
squinting
what's this uh an event for hot singles
[Laughter]
it says i need a shot to prevent
shingles
[Applause]
well either way i'll see you at
walgreens
that's the demo i'm in now where i get
unsolicited medical advice it just shows
up to show when i was younger when i
would see those medical commercials i'd
ignore them now i'm like oh get a pen
i i would like more information
i don't know maybe i do have
mesothelioma i don't know
did i work in a naval shipyard between
1932 and 1946
is that where i got shingles i don't
even know who i am anymore
i'll tell you who i feel bad for
women named karen
they've had a rough run
they have and sometimes they have
legitimate issues with customer service
they can't ask for the manager the
manager fight your name is karen well
why don't you take your weird backward
mullet haircut and get the hell out of
here
[Applause]
and i know this is a problem because i
have a friend named karen and she was
distraught she said to me this is
terrible i love my name and now people
use my name to mean an annoying white
woman it's unfair and i don't like it
and i said well look at you complaining
my name is joe devito thank you very
much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else